- Everyone in the world
has gone to bed one night
or another with fear, or pain,
or loss or disappointment.
And yet each of us has awakened arisen.
Somehow made our ablutions
in other human beings
and said morning how are yah?
Fine thanks and you?
It's amazing wherever that
abinds in the human being
there is the nobleness
of the human spirit.
Despite it all, black and
white, Asians, Spanish,
Native American, pretty, plain, thin, fat,
vowed or celibate, we rise.
(light music)
You may write me down in history,
with your bitter twisted lies.
You may trod me in the very dirt
but still like dust, I'll rise.
- Does my sassiness upset you?
Why are you beset with gloom?
Cause I walk like I've got oil wells
pumping in my living room.
- Just like moons and the suns,
with the certainty of tides,
just like hopes and
springing high, still I rise.
- Did you want to see me broken?
Bowed head and lowered eyes?
Shoulders falling down like teardrops,
weakened by my soulful cries?
- Does my haughtiness offend you?
Don't you take it awful hard,
cause I laugh like I've got gold mines
digging in my own backyard.
- You can shoot me with your words,
you can cut me with your lies,
you can kill me with your hatefulness,
but just like life, I'll rise.
- Does my sexiness upset you?
Does it come as a surprise?
That I dance like I've got diamonds
at the meeting of my thighs?
- Out of the huts of
history's shame, I rise.
- Up from a past that's
rooted rooted in pain, I rise.
I'm a black ocean, leaping and wide.
Welling and swelling I bear in the tide.
Leaving behind nights of
terror and fear, I rise.
- Into a daybreak miraculously clear,
I rise.
- Bringing the gifts that
my ancestors gave, I rise.
- I am the hope and the dream of the slave
and so (clapping).
There I go rising.
(light music)